如果你是一個25歲的投資人
你就開始做退休準備
那到65歲的時候
因為從現在25歲到未來40年
這期間的通貨膨脹率
所以450萬其實可能變得不夠用
等機票等你抽
心動不如行動
火速開戶做任務囉
各位觀眾朋友大家好我是阿雅
很多人一想要退休腦中第一個浮現的問題就是
到底要準備多少錢才夠
今天我們邀請到國立臺灣大學財務金融學系專任教授張森林
來告訴我們退休金額怎麼估怎麼存怎麼用
大家一起把
退休這件事
算清楚
想明白讓我歡迎張教授
張教授您好
阿雅好各位觀眾大家好
教授在退休規劃中常提到這個
這個所得替代率
也就是退休後的收入
要能夠替代原本工作的收入比例
那麼所得替代率應該怎麼定才合理
又會受到哪些因素影響呢
首先我想來提一下
就是說我們退休準備裡面
怎麼樣去決定我們的這個
退休理財的目標
那一般來講會有三個目標
所得替代率只是其中之一
所以第一個目標就是
退休所得一定要超過
最低生活費的標準
也就是所謂的貧窮線
因為如果你的退休所得低於這個
最低生活費的標準
那就代表沒有辦法過下去
所以這個是最基本的標準
那第二個標準
就是跟社會大眾來比
一般來講
我們會去參考
這個受薪階級的
他的平均的薪資
那會建議大概是50%左右
那比如說現在
這個全體受薪階級的平均薪資
可能大概接近6萬塊左右
那所以如果你的退休所得
有超過3萬塊以上
也就是一半的話
那將比較不會有相對的剝奪感
那第三個就是
就是剛剛主持人提到的
就是說這個所得替代率的概念
就是說自己跟自己比
我退休前的所得是多少
那我退休之後呢
希望能夠跟退休前
這個領的金額來比
一般的建議是至少可能要有
這個六成到七成的所得替代率
這樣才會過得跟以前一樣好
所以自己跟自己比是希望說
我退休以後能夠跟過的
跟以前一樣好的概念
是 那如果今天呢
我是大老闆 我是總經理
我賺的比較多
那我還需要就是六七十%
怎麼樣去決定一個合理的所得替代率
其實最重要的就是說
你退休前是高所得還是普羅大眾
還是說是低所得者
那像剛剛主持人講的
如果你退休前是總經理退休的
那你一個月薪資50萬
那退休後其實一個月就算只有15萬
也是可以過得很好
所以你的所得替代率就不需要太高
可能三成四成就非常的好
那一般的普羅大眾
就是我剛剛建議的
可能要把目標設在
所得替代率六成或七成
那如果是低薪的勞工
比如說你退休前一個月只賺兩萬五
那如果你在打個六折或七折
其實這個會過得不太好
所以低所得的人
他的所得替代率就需要比較高一點
可能至少要到八成
甚至九成以上會比較好
您強調退休理財的重點是設計現金流
那對一個普通上班族來說
該如何利用4%的法則
來反推自己需要準備多少退休金
才能達到70%的所得替代率呢
我們退休以後就是要去考量
我的退休所得的來源有哪一些
那一般來講
大部分的民眾退休所得的來源
可能有三個
那第一個就是社會保險的年金
社會保險年金當然是看
你是什麼樣的身分別
勞工就是勞保年金
那沒有工作的家庭主婦
他可能是領國民年金
那軍公教他就是公保年金
所以社會保險年金是第一層的這個所得
而且它通常就是以年金的形式
每個月領的方式
這個是第一層所得來源
那第二層的這個所得來源叫職業退休金
也就是老闆給你的退休金
那以勞工來講
如果你是勞基法就職的話
那就是按照你的年資來決定說
你可以領幾個月的這個退休金
那如果是勞退薪制
現在就是用提撥制
所以僱主會每個月提撥6%
到你的這個個人勞退薪資的個人帳戶制
那當然有一些勞工其實他就沒有僱主的退休金
像那個職業工會的勞工
因為他沒有一定的僱主
所以就沒有僱主幫他提撥這個職業退休金
所以這個是職業退休金的這個部分
那軍公教職業退休金是最優渥的
因為軍公教的這個退輔
他這就屬於職業退休金
多一點
那第三層就是我們個人儲蓄的這個部分
那個人儲蓄的部分就是看本事
所以我們平常要養成這個儲蓄投資的習慣
那所以你就會累積你的這個個人的財富
那個人財富里面其實也包括不動產
所以很多人他退休以後
其實他最大的財富是他的房子
那這個也可以拿來作為退休金的這個
儲備的一部分
但還是需要一些現金
對對對沒錯
那你如果做股票債券這些ETF的投資
那這個基本上未來就可以創造現金流
那我就舉一個例子來說明說
我們怎麼樣去規劃這個退休以後的現金流
那我以一個退休前每個月領五萬塊的勞工來做例子好了
那如果說他的第一層的這個勞保年金
將按照這個勞保年金的幾副公司
他每一個月可以領一萬八千塊
那我們就先把它記下來
那第二層就是他的職業退休金
那他可能是適用這個勞退薪資
也就是他的個人賬戶制
那到他退休的時候累積的金額
我們假設累積有60萬
那這時候我們就可以用4%法則來決定說
這60萬可以每個月產生多少現金流
那所以60萬的4%就是24000
所以每個月就是2000塊
所以那還要決定我們的所得替代率
假設他定定的所得替代率的目標是70%
那也就是一個月要有三萬五千塊
那所以三萬五千塊扣掉這個勞保一千
一萬八千塊
然後再扣掉剛剛講勞退薪資
我們自己把它年金化每個月兩千塊
所以扣完之後
你的缺口就是每個月至少要有這個一萬五千塊
透過私人儲蓄來產生這個現金流
那我們在同樣透過這個4%法則
這時候你就是需要300倍的這個每個月的缺口
每個月缺口15000塊
所以300倍就是450萬
所以你就退休的時候
最好能夠累積到450萬的這個本金
來作為退休的這個未來的現金流所需要
剛剛教授說就是乘以300嘛
那這個300是指300個月嗎
是的沒有錯
就是說其實你就是可以想成說
你每個月的缺口是多少錢
那這個缺口你要準備25年
300個月這樣
你缺口是15000塊對不對
對 然後乘以300個月450萬
那450萬你乘以4%呢
是多少 18萬
18萬除以12個月
剛好一個月就是1萬5
就是65歲往後推25年
對 所以就是90歲
對 那這個就是你需要的本金的金額
教授如果要把退休金缺口
那你剛說是450萬補足嘛
那用不同年齡階段
再搭配不同的風險屬性
現在開始每個月要存多少錢
才補得起來呢
那會建議投資人
能不能透過定期定額的方式
每個月固定投入股市嗎
這個退休金的缺口準備
其實是越早開始準備越好
如果說你到65歲的時候
需要累積450萬的這個本金的話
那這個最關鍵的決定因素
主要就是你的這個準備期間的長短
還有你的這個投資報酬率
那在投資報酬率方面
其實有兩個決定因素
一個就是投資人自己選擇的投資組合
另外一個就是市場來決定
因為市場未來的這個報酬率好壞
它有運氣的成分在
那舉例來講
如果是一個投資人
他非常的保守
他終身都是做這個
定存或者是債券的投資
那運氣再怎麼好
他的投資報酬率
可能就是5%左右
那如果說他從25歲
就開始準備的話
那大概每一個月
可能需要準備這個3000塊
就定期定額去做投資
那如果他等到45歲
才開始去做準備
只剩下20年
那這時候他的金額
就需要提高到一萬一千塊
對壓力就會比較大
那甚至如果說他到55歲才開始準備
那他每個月就要存兩萬九千塊
那這個壓力又更大
那如果說他運氣不好一點
因為他做這樣的投資
5%已經是算是運氣很好的一個投報率了
那如果運氣不好
他只有3%的投報率的話
那他每個月存的錢呢
可能至少要多這個20%以上
所以我想就是說
其實這個投報率的部分
有一些部分是投資人自己選擇的投資組合來決定
一部分是運氣的成分
從這些數字裡面
這個總表你有沒有可以看到
越早準備你需要的金額是越低的
那如果你是一個年輕的投資人的話
建議其實你可以採取比較積極的投資組合
所以比如說
如果你是用世界股價指數的基金或ETF
做40年的投資
你從25歲就開始做退休準備的話
那其實你每個月不到2000塊就可以達標
因為這個根據這個過去歷史經驗來講
這個世界股價指數的這個長期表現
年化報酬率超過7%的機率是很高的
所以從25歲開始定期定額的話
其實負擔的會比較低
他的這個需要每個月需要存的金額就會少非常的多
因為你可以長期享受這個負利的效果
就是每個月要存的錢是會比你想像中的要低非常多
所以其實我們一個看似安全的這個投資的這個方式
其實在長期投資反而是不利的
因為我們剛剛在這個例子裡面可以發現
就是說你很保守的投資人
你如果做長期投資的話
你要準備很多的本金
才有辦法達到你的投資目標
那這450萬的這個退休金缺口
我們就沒有就是考慮到這個通膨嗎
以這個例子來講
如果你是一個25歲的投資人
你就開始做退休準備
那到65歲的時候
你設定目標是450萬
其實是不切實際的
因為從現在25歲到未來40年
這期間的通貨膨脹率
可能物價至少可能漲了兩倍或三倍
所以450萬其實可能變得不夠用
所以我會給投資人建議
我們應該從這個所得替代率的
這個觀念來看
看我的儲蓄率是多少
其實剛剛那個總表他有
還有另外一個缺點就
其實
40年前每個月存1800多塊
可能是
很多的一個金額
但是現在來講又
嫌太少了因為我們薪資其實在成長
所以你40年前
你薪資那麼低的情況底下你就要每個月存1800多塊
我覺得這是
不太切實際的
那現在來講
一個月存1800多塊又太少了
所以我們正確的這個儲蓄的方式
應該是隨著薪資的這個變動
我們要去調整我們的投資的這個比例
所以我們用儲蓄率來看說
如果我設定一個所得替代率的目標
那我每個月對應的儲蓄率應該是多少
所以我就舉例來說明
假設你設定的所得替代率目標是70%
那你全部都是要靠自己的私人儲蓄
來達到這樣的目標
那你現在每個月到底要存多少錢
才能夠達到這個目標
同樣的這個
還是受到你的這個報酬率的影響
所以我這邊這個總表裡面
試算了三種的這個實質投資報酬率
所謂的實質投資報酬率
就是明目的這個報酬率
要扣掉通貨膨脹率
或者是扣掉這個薪資成長率
那我這個總表的計算裡面
是假設這個通貨膨脹率
跟這個薪資成長率是一樣的
然後呢我一樣是用這個4%法則
就是說我退休
如果要達到這樣的一個替代率
那我要準備300個月的這個退休金
所以基於這樣的方式呢
我就去做一個計算
其實如果你是很保守的投資人
比如說你只做活存跟定存
其實你的報酬率是負的
過去的歷史資料可以看得出來
就是說你只做活存跟定存
你會被通膨吃掉
所以你的報酬率反而是負的
所以我這邊試算的是負0.25%
那如果你是做一個穩健的投資組合
合理來講
可能你的實質投資報酬率長期來講大概是2.5%左右
那如果你是一個比較積極的投資組合
大概實質投資報酬率很有可能可以來到4.5%
所以我用三個不同的實質投資報酬率來試算一下
如果你是從25歲開始準備
35歲 45歲乃至於55歲
那你每個月的儲蓄率要是多少
才可以達到所得替代率這個70%的這個目標
那其實結論跟剛剛非常的接近
就是說你越早準備
你的儲蓄率會越低
所以比如說
如果你是一個年輕人
而且你從25歲
就開始很積極的去做投資
選擇積極的投資組合
你的實質投資報酬率
可以來到4.5%
那你每個月的
大概只要存16%的薪資
你就可以
未來就有機會
可以達到70%的所得替代率
那當然你月完準備
比如說你到了45歲
才開始準備退休金
那你每個月的儲蓄率
就要大概55%左右
那如果你是比較
你又選擇保守的投資方式
那這樣你的儲蓄率就要提高不少
比如說如果你是很保守
你就做活存跟定存
那你又45歲才開始去準備退休金的話
那你每個月的儲蓄率就要高達90%
這幾乎是不可能的
就沒有辦法就是花在生活費上面
對所以這個表
我覺得很值得投資人去參考
就是說你看了這個表之後
你就知道說怎麼樣去做投資
而且要越早越好
所以及早透過定期定額將資金投入股市
不僅分散進場失點的風險
又有助於長期資產的累積
在進行定期定額投資時
除了自行挑選有興趣的標的外
也可以參考富邦證券近期推出的三大投資組合
包括精選主動型投資組合
高息存股投資組合
以及AI趨勢投資組合
透過組合式的配置一次掌握多元標的
輕鬆建立完善的佈局
操作也非常簡單
只要進入AI Pro
點選臺美股定期定額
再進入找標的類別
即可在投資組合頁面中
選擇合適自己的投資組合
快速打造個人化的定期定額投資策略
接著我們想再請教教授
近期黃金的價格屢創新高
那另外也許多投資人開始關注
加密貨幣這樣的另類資產
你認為這些資產
在以退休為目標的投資組合中
應該佔有一席之地嗎
那如果要配置的話
建議的投資比例是多少呢
黃金要不要納入退休資產的
這個投資組合裡面其實見仁見智
比如說巴菲特他就認為說
黃金沒有這個股息的收入
或債息的收入
所以他基本面比較弱
所以他就不建議說
去投資黃金
但是另外有一個投資大神叫 Ray Dalio
他有設計一個叫全天候的投資組合
那他就有把黃金納入投資組合
不過這邊要注意的
就是說你即使把黃金納入
你的退休投資組合
那個比例也不應該太高
比如說這個全天候投資組合裡面
黃金的比重其實只有7.5%
Ray Dalio他把它納入的原因是認為說
黃金還是有這個風險分散的效果
所以他把它納入
但是比例不宜太高
像加密貨幣這種另類投資
我個人是不太贊成的
因為它基本上是用演算法創造出來的
那即使是像比特幣這種
因為它的演算法會讓它的數量比較有限
然後它又有去中心化的這些好處
所以這幾年的漲勢非常的高
但是我仍然覺得它沒有基本面的支撐
所以不值得投資
它其實就跟黃金一樣
黃金沒有股息跟債息的收入
所以加密貨幣也沒有收入的來源
所以它的基本面其實是更弱的
黃金至少還有實體的資產
黃金也可以作為珠寶的製造的原料
所以它還有一些基本價值的存在
但是加密貨幣在我看起來
其實是完全沒有基本面的一個資產
其實投資人投資加密貨幣
期待的就是說它未來價格會上漲
除了這個之外其實它沒有任何的好處
可是一個虛的東西
我們怎麼有辦法期待說它未來會持續的上漲呢
尤其是現在像比特幣這種加密貨幣
它現在價格已經非常高了
其實比特幣的總市值
現在已經高達全世界股市的總市值的2%以上
甚至就是超過了臺積電的總市值
那你不會覺得說這樣的風險非常的高嗎
對 那它在這麼高的一個基期底下
我覺得它未來上漲的潛力
一定會受到很大的限制
再從另外一個角度來講
其實我以前的指導教授跟我講過
你不懂的東西其實不要去碰
那其實加密貨幣這種東西
其實對大部分的投資人
他都不瞭解它運作的機制
純粹就是看漲
然後聽很多網紅的推薦
那其實我們金融市場裡面已經有非常好的這個金融商品存在
為什麼要去冒這個風險去投資這些
我們看不懂的這些另類資產
所以我個人是非常不贊成說去投資這種加密貨幣的
那加密貨幣現在大家比較看好了
其實是它可以作為交易的媒介
所以像穩定幣很多普遍被用來作為交易的媒介
這個我倒是比較持中性的看法
但是如果你是用投資的目的
去買這個加密貨幣
我覺得是要注意它的風險
我覺得個人是不太推薦
最後想請教授
當我們實際到退休階段
會有使用現金的壓力
想請教授幫我們比較幾種
常見的貼領方式
第一種的話是像4%法則一樣
定期定額賣出ETF獲取現金
第二種的話則是透過
極限年金險或是目標日期基金
來產生現金流
您會建議混用兩種工具嗎
其實因為現在金融科技的發展
所以其實像如果你需要
就是產生現金流的話
你不一定要去買配息型的基金
我們可以去找這個適當的金融機構
它推出的這個服務
然後就可以產生我們需要的現金流
或者是找適當的這個金融商品的工具
所以比如第一個來講
如果我們採用4%法則的話
其實我不需要自己去定期定額賣基金
或ETF
因為現在有一些這個基金的銷售平臺
他已經有提供這樣的服務
那他可以讓你定期定額賣這個基金或ETF
只是說這個每個月要賣的這個金額
是你自己要去決定的
比如說你退休的時候
你已經累積了600萬的這個共同基金或ETF
那你用4%法則
你每個月應該就可以賣出2萬塊的基金或ETF
那你也不用自己每個月手動去操作
不用就是利用這個金融科技的服務
這是第一種方式
那第二種方式就是剛剛主持人講
其實你可以去購買這個集體年金險
所謂的集體年金險就是說
你在退休的時候
你把一大筆錢拿給保險公司
然後從這個下個月開始
保險公司每個月就會給你年金
所以你就有年金的收入
這是第二個方式
第三種方式可以採用的金融商品
就是透過這個目標日期基金
你在退休前呢
你選擇很方便
比如說你如果是2029要退休的
這個投資人
你就選2029目標日期基金
如果你是2039左右退休了
你就選擇2039
那他會按照你的到期日越來越接近
他就會降低這個投資部位的風險
所以一個比較晚到期的目標日期基金
他前期這個股票的比例是很高的
但是他到了接近退休
最接近這個到期日的時候
他的這個債券的比例
就會超過股票的比例
所以他風險就會開始降低
所以這是他的好處
就是它自然達到我們財務上
所謂的生命週期的投資法的這個方式
那第二個好處就是現金流的好處
所以有一些目標日期基金
它的設計理念是這樣
它到期之後呢
它會分比如說15年或20年
慢慢把它解散
也就是每個月把它的這個資產
賣掉一部分的比例
然後退還給投資人
那投資人自然就收到了錢
就可以作為他的年金
所以就有了現金流
非常感謝教授今天的分享
今天我們從所得替代率與4%的法則
來推估退休金需要準備多少
你學會了嗎
下一集我們會帶大家瞭解TISA制度
對TISA制度還不瞭解的朋友千萬不要錯過
最後喜歡我們的影片也不要忘記
訂閱按贊開啟小鈴鐺
我們下集再見
拜拜